at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question
now soon I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by on it I have used on it products for
years if you look in my kitchen in my
garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it calm
forward-slash Tim that's onn IT comm
forward slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it comm forward
slash Tim the Tim Ferriss show is also
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
your one-stop shop for anything graphic
design related you need a logo you need
a website you need a business card or
anything else you get an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy where you get your money back and
I have used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the 4-hour body which went to
number one New York Times for banner ads
and you can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim you can also get a
free $99 upgrade if you want to give it
a shot
that's 99designs comm forward slash Tim
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to a very special
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where
each episode I attempt to deconstruct
world-class performers to find what
makes them tick the tools and tricks
that you can use in your daily life
ranging from professional athletes to
chess prodigies to billionaire investors
- in this episode that's right
Arnold Schwarzenegger the man himself
the governador the Terminator the man
who killed the goddamn predator people
this was an amazing experience for me of
course there are many things that I
associate with my upbringing if you want
to call it that in the 80s Guns N'Roses
but of course there's commando
there's predator the list goes on and on
this man is a force of nature and I had
the opportunity the rare opportunity to
visit him at his home in Southern
California at the kitchen table we dug
into everything and I really wanted to
dig into areas that had not been
explored widely in any other interviews
that I could find and that ranges from
the art of psychological warfare he is a
master how did he apply that what
phrases did he use questions that he
used to get inside the heads of his
opponents we cover that what was his
most lucrative movie I'll give you a
hint
twins how the hell did that happen well
there's a lot that goes into the
backstory of that how did he make
millions of dollars fresh off the boat
before his acting career took off a lot
of people don't realize he was a
millionaire before his acting career
took off how did that happen we dig into
it how did Arnold use meditation for one
year and just one year to completely
reset his brain and prime the stage for
massive success and of course mailing
cow balls to politicians but that's just
the tip of the iceberg this was an
amazing episode I want to let you get
right into it
the show notes links all that good stuff
will be found at 4-hour workweek all
spelled out for our work week com click
on podcast or you can just go to 4-hour
workweek comm /a
Arnold and without further ado please
enjoy a wild romp through the life of
Arnold Schwarzenegger and sir I wanted
to start with a thank you for welcoming
me to your house number one but number
two I felt awkward all morning because I
don't know how I should address you and
I wanted to ask you how I should address
you well you can address me there any
way you want you can call me Governator
governor schnitzel okay but I think I'll
be right I'll go with Arnold it's it's I
felt like my first year in Japan when I
was 15 because I didn't know how to
address anybody so I figured we could
start with a favorite topic well it's
become a favorite topic as I've been
thinking about this which is big balls
and cow balls and bull testicles
so you've mailed sculptures of bull
testicles to people before is that right
well there was one incident in
particular that was when I was governor
and there was you know one of the the
leaders legislative leaders Darrell
Steinberg and I we both had a huge
challenge
California was hit by an enormous you
know economic decline there was a
worldwide recession that was hitting us
in 2008 and everyone kind of was caught
by surprise of what the fact that had
did all of a sudden we had twenty
billion dollars less in revenues
therefore we had to make big cuts in
education and in various different areas
that really hit the vulnerable citizens
of California and so when we did the
budget I basically sent him up before we
negotiated you know a set of balls and
and you know kind of just be the note
that say I hope you have that maybe
negotiate the budget because that's what
we both need but there will be all in
this building need in order to get this
budget done because it's not going to be
a pretty budget
because people will hate it they were
haters you know they'd be making those
cuts but it's all the money we have and
so he didn't take it lightly did he take
it well or did he take it seriously oh
no biggie he took it seriously kind of
like what happened is is that you said
I've done it before and it's kind of
things that I do you know I do always in
the pranks and people and jokes and
stuff like that but it's always kind of
meant with a sense of humor
right you know so it's always when you
and I always have this tendency that
when things get really intense and when
people start dinner freaking out
I try to make a joke or something to do
lighten things up and just say look you
know 10 years from now we're going to
look at this day and laugh about it
right now it's very serious and then now
we're you know we have to you know
really concentrate on this and if it do
something that we don't feel comfortable
whatever the situation is in this case
if the capital this was the situation it
was a terrible situation that we were in
the economically and I thought they were
loosen it up before the the legislative
leaders come down you know to my office
since we start go see ating and it just
didn't go very well I mean he felt
insulted and he felt hurt and he felt
how could I do this notice that you know
I said I said look I'm sorry I did not
mean it that way don't think it's a
seriously it was meant to be a joke this
things happen you know they youth you're
no stranger to adversity of course when
you grew up in a very small village in
Austria you had I think splash toilet or
what was the the nickname for it they
basically a chamber pot it's a sponge
toilet yes exactly
and basically it's it's like an outhouse
but it is in the house and you know you
sit there and you know and you hear
maybe a second later after you know a
equal number two you hear then they
plush because it's what I called as
flush the toilet and and they said that
was a common thing in in old buildings
our building was like two hundred and
some years old and there was you know
there was no of a flushing toilet
there was also no running water in our
house where I grew up and so we had to
get basically the water from around 100
to 200 yards away from a way out that we
had the pump and winter and summer
didn't make any difference and we had to
carry the buckets of water to our house
to our kitchen and then it was used very
sparingly
we drank from dead water we washed
ourselves with did water there was no
shower so we washed ourselves with
washcloths and with soap and there was a
whole kind of a you know but everyone
had the position my mother went first
and washed herself and then it was my
father's turn and then it was my
brothers journal by the time I wash
myself the laboum of that base where the
water was in was pretty black I know I
said it was not brilliant
I may be good but they're less terms of
water before they actually clean myself
good idea to drink first make sure you
say your but the interesting thing about
it was it was you know other places had
exactly the same situation we were not
the only one so we didn't feel that kind
of wow you know we really growing up or
as a matter of fact I never felt when I
was a kid that we were poor I always
felt like we were like everyone else
because we were surrounded by farmers
that had very little money they had
little farms or workers the working
class with workers made actually less
money than my dad my dad didn't make
much money at all because he was a
police officer and there was much more
the benefits the you know that the
pension that you get the healthcare all
the stuff but not much salary just
enough that my mother goodbye to buy the
groceries and to buy some things and
once a year that buy clothes at
Christmas time for us or to knit some
clothes for us and stuff like that so
but I mean there was like the neighbors
were living the same way and everyone
when I went to school all the other kids
were kind of in the same boat and which
brings up a question for me that I've
always wanted to ask you related to
confidence because I was looking at of
course I think your name is almost
synonymous with confidence for a lot of
people and people look to you to try to
borrow confidence and that's part of the
appeal of a lot of your movies and your
successes but I was looking at
very old photograph of I think your
first major bodybuilding competition in
Stuttgart I think it was the junior mr.
Europe and I looked at this photograph
and what stuck out to me was if we had
just looked at the faces not the bodies
it was so clear to me that you were
going to win and that you knew or
believed you were going to win your face
was so confident compared to every other
competitor where did that confidence
come from my confidence came from my
vision because I am always a big
believer that if you have a very clear
vision of where you want to go then the
rest of it is much easier because you
know always why you're training five
hours a day you always know why you're
pushing and going through the pain
barrier and why do you have to eat more
and why do you have to struggle more why
do you have to be more disciplined and
all of those things become much more
clear it's not like oh my god I have to
do another you know two hundred sit-ups
it's more kind of like I can't wait to
do another 200 sit-ups because that will
get me one step closer to if the apps
that I need to win that mr. universe and
that's my goal I see myself clearly on
that stage winning the mr. universe I
see myself very clearly of getting the
trophy standing there with the trophy
raising it above my head and having
hundreds of bodybuilders around me kind
of below me on stage looking up and
idolizing me including the thousands of
people that are watching the event so
there was always made clear vision and
dead always inspired me to go all out
and so when I went for competition you
have to understand I went from the to
the junior mr. Europe during my time in
the military and so what it took for me
to go and to get on that train
the personam souk which was that
people's train meaning kind of like this
was nothing Chanel took at the end of
the fast train it was the slow train
that literally stopped and every train
station to let broker's often to bring
new workers on and that's what the train
was and
with that you get went to all the way to
Stuttgart because it was the cheapest
way of going because I didn't have much
money and you didn't get hit by any
customs officers well we got hit but the
minute we got through it you know and I
didn't have my passport because you had
to give up the past but when you go into
the military right so you pass I didn't
have a past but pass but we got
afterwards when we were finished with
the military but the mean so if we got
through and we got to the Germany the
Stuttgart and so there was this will via
didn't no matter what it takes and even
if I have to crawl to Germany that I
will be there at that event because
there was my shot when I saw the ads
about this mr. Europe junior competition
best keep out the outlet or opus in
German and and that that was my
opportunity to really go and to make my
first kind of entry and doing in the
national competition and I felt that you
know I can win it and that's what I was
there for I wasn't there to compete I
was did to win and and so that's why you
saw that facial expression there was a
certain arrogance there there was a
certain way that I posed with the other
competitors
I always felt during the pose-off that I
had my act together much more than the
others did and then I'm gonna you know
kind of you know make them feel inferior
and and I will win and I will look
facially and physically to the judges
that I'm the champion so you touched on
something I really wanted to get into
which is the the the psychological
warfare of bodybuilding of life in
general I really feel and this is a
compliment mean it is compliment a real
master and if anyone who's watched
pumping iron or or anything I think
comes away with one that is a take away
uh how did you doubt it'd you develop
that and for instance when you were I
guess seventeen or eighteen how did you
get inside the heads of those people at
that point I think they did it uh came
about when I trained in the gym
I always felt that people are kind of
really vulnerable in certain areas so
that someone that comes to the gym and
works out because he wants to have a
better body that he most likely will be
vulnerable that's during conversations
that I discovered in Munich when it was
trained in the gym they were vulnerable
when you say something like you're fat
well it was it was it was not like even
a doubt in anyone's mind if ten people
would have looked at that guy or a
hundred people they all would have said
that this guy's fat but he was outraged
he said what do you really think I'm
that fat that you mention it as it were
you in the gym as I go to the doctor's
office and say I have a cough I don't go
and beat around the bush I say I have to
tell him what the problem isn't then he
can give me the medication I said this
the same thing in the gym as you come
here because you're [ __ ] fat and so
the dead listen now that's off the
problem and so there's no beating around
the bush there either and so you know so
I could see that they were kind of like
shriveling up and kind of shocked so I
could see the vulnerability and then I
tried different lines and people and
then I will talk about the idea the hair
line where we talk about the hair color
turning gray and then they it would just
freak out you know about little things
like that so it was natural that with
all the experience that I got not being
a trained and working with people and
orders that I learned about people's
psychology and about the weaknesses and
the strengths and orders how do you
build people up because my whole thing
was let's first discover and talk about
the weakness and then let's go and
rebuild everything and so that was the
idea to give this guy six-pack to make
him feel great to declare victory by
next summer that he can go to the beach
and that he can go and feel proud of
himself and feel great and orders and
then continue training so there was the
idea so by the time I came to America
and instead of the end up competing over
here it was very clear that when I said
to someone let me ask you something is
if you have any knee injuries or
something like that then this they would
say they will look at me and say now why
my book no up knowing only injury at all
no my knees feel great and they say are
you asking I said because your thighs
look a little slimmer to me I mean I
thought maybe you can squat there maybe
there's some problem with laying
extension but I mean this is really and
then I saw them all for two hours in the
gym always going in front of the mirror
and checking out the thighs
if the thigh still existed something
telling me this is you know people get
people I've owned about those things so
naturally when you now have a
competition you use olders yeah and so
did you use you ask people with a sick
for a while you know what it look at
lalena or that you know you know did you
take in you salty foods lately and they
say why I said because it looks like if
water retention is he don't look as
ripped as you were like a week ago sir
so they throws people off in an
unbelievable way naked and they walk
away kind of like oh this isn't part of
them at all but then you can see you
watch them as they walk around the
pumpup room and when you warm up for the
competition and you could see them kind
of thinking to themselves kind of then
going the mural and checking it out
secretly in order itself so you know it
works er I just slowly developed it
because I always felt that sports are
not just a physical thing as a matter
fact I felt that the mentality and the
mental strength in sports in the
psychology in sports is much more
important than the physical thing
because in reality I mean I see when I
watch a mr. Olympia competition or mr.
universe competition or any of those
things you know they all look pretty
much the same the top five guys but what
makes one emerge is the way he act if he
acts like a winner he seems smiling
having a great time on stage in those so
I felt in no one should use the
psychology well one should use
everything in as far as food supplements
is concerned you use your based best you
know posing trunks use you know try to
use the Sun out there and work out in
the Sun so you get tanned all around use
the best posing routine just really give
me a ten of everything then you have a
shot
and in psychology was definitely part of
that and you developed this this arsenal
of intimidation through the the body
building did you use that for instance
in movies waiting in line to audition
against other people who were going in
to audition or anything like that did it
there did it apply to show business
I never addition okay I never it would
because I would never go out for the
regular parts because I was not a
regular looking guy so my idea always
was okay everyone is going to look the
same and everyone is trying to be the
plant guy in California going to
Hollywood interviews and then looking
somewhat athletic and cute and orders
okay how can I care for myself at the
niche that is unique that only I have
and so I always felt like really strong
about you know I have to get into the
movie business like reg Park did or like
Steve Reeves or Paul window Larry Gordon
and in orders in orders guys that were
in the muscle movies in the in the 50s
and 60s that's the way I'm going to get
in there of course you know the
naysayers were right there and they said
well you know this time has passed this
was 20 years ago you look too big you
too monstrous too muscular
you would never get in the movie so
that's what producers said in the
beginning in Hollywood and it's also
what agent said managers they said I
doubt that you're going to be successful
in that because the day's idols I mean
this is not the seventies Arnold the
days idols are they know Dustin Hoffman
Al Pacino Woody Allen I mean look is all
little guys you know those are the sex
symbols those are the hot stars look at
you you weigh 250 pounds or something
like that this is that time is over and
but I felt still very strongly and at a
very clear vision that the time will
come where someone would appreciate that
and then sure enough you know when
people saw me on talk shows
they got inspired directors like Bob
Rafelson
and then you know bought the script of
stay hungry the book of stay hungry and
had it written into the script and then
did the movie with me because he
believed in me that I had the person
didn't add a certain strength and a
certain kind of a look that would be
great on the screen that the camera
loves me and ordered and so it worked I
did stay hungry I did then pumping on
the documentary and you know did the
streets of San Francisco and worked then
within Margaret and with Kirk Douglas
and the villain and then all of a sudden
I got the contract for Conan the
Barbarian and bang there we were 20
million dollar movie which today will be
a equivalent of a two hundred million
dollar movie and Dino De Laurentiis
producing Universal Studio an
international studio you know financing
the movie and so it was in Chiang Milius
a first-class director directing it so
my whole plan worked and I was so right
even John Milius after he has done the
movie he said if we wouldn't have had
Schwarzenegger we would have had to
build one because of the body and when I
did Terminator Jim Cameron said if we
wouldn't have edged watts [ __ ] and we
couldn't have done the movie because
only because he sounded like a machine
was it so believable that he actually
played the Machine and that's where
people bought in when he says I'll be
back it's totally different than when I
say I'll be back kind of thing is so so
so he was the greatest compliment that
the very things that they the agents and
the managers and the studio executives
said would be a total obstacle became an
asset and the my career started taking
off so the the not auditioning is really
interesting to me
and I I knew you were very successful in
real estate but correct me if I'm wrong
you had basically made become a
millionaire in real estate before your
first movie is that right not before the
first movie before my career took off
got it so I did not rely on my movie
career to make a living because there
was many my intention because I saw over
the years that the people that worked
out in the gym and did I met in the
acting classes they all were very
vulnerable because they didn't have any
money and they had to take anything that
was offered to them because that was the
living
I didn't want to get into that situation
I felt like if I am smart with real
estate and take my little money that I'm
making body building and bid seminars
and selling my courses through the
mail-order in orders I could save up
enough money to put down money for an
apartment building and I realized that
in the 70s the inflation rate was very
high and therefore an investment like
that is like unbeatable because
buildings that I would buy for $500,000
you know within the year were eight
hundred thousand dollars and I only put
them maybe a hundred down so you know
you made three hundred percent on your
money so you couldn't you couldn't beat
that so I quickly developed and traded
up my buildings in Baltimore apartment
buildings and office buildings on Main
Street down in Santa Monica and so on
and the investments were very good and
it was just one of this magic decade the
day you couldn't do it in that same
field there's another field in real
estate where you can do that but in this
particular field I don't think you will
see those kind of chumps ever again and
I benefited from that and I became a
millionaire from my real estate
investments and there was before my
career took off in show business in
acting which was after Conan the
Barbarian in 1982 that movie came out be
shouted in 81 and in 82 he came out so
from that point on my career took off
because people saw you know that the
movie was successful at the box office
then you know I signed a contract to do
conan number two and you know then that
led to a contract the you know with the
four Terminator 1 and 10 commander and
it you know then the action genre also
there was another fortunate thing each
of those decades offered something very
fortunate that was a little bit beyond
my control but I benefited from that you
know so that there was the action genre
did all of a sudden took off in the 80s
with Stallone and phantom and all those
guys coming in really was terrific and
you know our salaries went in a mine we
are good like a million dollars for
Terminator 2 and then all of a sudden by
the end of the decade I made 20 million
dollars
that's incredible and uh so I wanted to
talk
about the mail-order for a second
because that was done with with Franco
Columbu wrote the bit Franco Columbu who
for those that don't know is a European
was a European champion in powerlifting
and also a boxing champion and then
became a bodybuilding champion and then
he I brought him over here with Joey
does help to train with me here in
America but at that point there was no
money in bodybuilding that's the key
thing that everyone has to understand
unlike the day where the top
bodybuilding Champions make millions of
dollars in those days there was no money
in bodybuilding and so when we didn't
have enough money we literally had to go
to work and so Frank and I since
Franco's talent was to be a bricklayer
and it's very skilled bricklayer and
learned that in Italy and in Germany we
were able to go and start thinking about
the idea of putting an ad in the LA
Times creating a company and calling it
European bricklayers and masonry experts
marble experts building chimneys and
fireplaces the European style and this
was also a time where everything that
was European was huge in America
so we benefited from that you know
Swedish massages and everything had to
be kind of a foreign name or a Japanese
this and they said so Europe and Japan
and all those places you know were used
the names were used because for some
reason that the other people just
thought that was better and so we used
that in the ad and we put the ad in the
paper and literally a week later we had
the big earthquake in Los Angeles
I mean the chimneys fell after the
apartment houses and orders of and had
cracked walls and orders and so Frank
and I we as America one of the friend of
ours wife who was very smart and she
worked in a supermarket she did
answering the phones and calling people
back and orders just to make sure that
in English doesn't get all screwed up
with the talking over the phone and
orders and and and said she they
versed in the addresses and then we got
to do the estimates and I was kind of
like set up to be the math genius and
then figures out the square footage and
that Franco would play the bad guy and I
play the good guy
and so we would go to someone's house
and then someone would say well look at
my patio is all cracked can you guys put
the new patio in here and I would say
yes and then we run around with the tape
measure but there would be a dead
measure with centimeters no one in those
days could it all figure out anything
with centimeters and we will be
measuring up and I say vertices you know
four and meters in to 82 centimeters and
they had no idea we're talking about and
this is so much and then we will be
writing up formulas and the dollars and
amounts and square centimeters and
square meters and all this stuff and
then I will go to the guy and I said
well I said it's $5,000 and the guy will
be in a state of shock and you say sits
$5,000 I said this is outrageous I said
they didn't think that this is a well
what did you expect it in the basis I
thought maybe it's like two three
thousand dollars is about five thousand
it says a cinema sit let me talk to my
guys is because he's really the masonry
expert I said but I can beat him down
for a little bit here let me soften the
meat and then said we'll go over to
Franco and we were still arguing in
German you know this is any finer writer
constantly so far along and this is
employed sneezing me I met here in
America and this will be going on he was
screaming back him in Italian and some
stuff and then ever be then always nd
calm down and never go to the guys at
who okay here is it I could get him as
low as $3,800 I say can you go with that
and he says thank you very much he says
you know III really think that you're a
great man bla bla bla notice that I say
okay I say give us half down right now
we go right away and get the cement and
get the bricks and everything that we
need for you and you start working I
said a Monday and the guy was ecstatic
you gave us the money we immediately ran
to the bank cashed the check is to make
sure that the money's in the bank
account and then we went out and got the
cement the wheelbarrow
the stuff that we needed and went to
Brooke and so we worked like that for
two years I mean very successfully as a
metric than and we had the various
different jobs will be employed like 16
different bodybuilders all the laziest
bastard said you can never hire but
never the because they all were
interested in working out door and
getting a tan at the same time for the
bodybuilding competitions they were not
interested in working but anyways if we
all had a good time we all made money
and you know friend this is actually
then I did this until I started my
mail-order business and then that became
the news to us of extra income so we
could afford everything and then save
also some money and so on and so I
should say of course but I've followed
followed you since I was a little kid
also Franco though I remember watching
the replay of the World's Strongest Man
competition in the refrigerator right
walk when his leg gave out but I was
always impressed by how uh how strong he
was for his weight I mean I think he's
dead lifted more than 750 pounds at less
than 190 or something like that
why did beat the 7:30 he did like five
reps that's generous and was like and
how what are the reasons the two of you
have remained a remain friends for so
long I think we both come from Europe I
think we both was struggling on the
beginning I met Franco the day off the
mr. Europe jr. competition that same day
he won the powerlifting Championships in
the lightweight category and so he was
up there on the stage getting his trophy
I was up down the stage getting my
trophy and then the category of
bodybuilding championship of the world
past 18 years of age which would they
call the senior division but it was not
really senior what they consider now he
is senior being over 45 or whatever it
is but I mean then it was just someone
that was older than 18 he was up there
the winner on stage so there was all
three of us on stage and then you know
Franco worked out the Munich Necedah my
said I want to come to Munich able to
work out in Munich
after the military is finished and you
know Franco said well and I'm I'm there
if you ever come he says let's work out
together and I told him that I admire
powerlifting that I do powerlifting and
weightlifting and bodybuilding and I
want to work out with him and get
stronger and so when I'm basically moved
to Munich
Franco was one of the first guys that
ever went to see and ask him before us
to be my training partner now Franco
didn't train as much as I did at that
time so I used several training partners
but Franco was one of them and we just
developed a really great friendship
because he was a foreigner in Germany he
was a what they call it cast out by the
and I was considered the gospel and I'm
in a kind of a guest from the outside
from Austria coming to Germany and you
know we developed a really close
relationship so we trained for two years
together he helped me with the
powerlifting I helped him with the
bodybuilding and then by 1968 I moved to
California and I convinced Joe Weider
then to give Franco a LN ticket bring
him over here that he would not regret
it that he is really what I am embodying
except in a short man category the
champion is like the ultimate as it is
no one better and he's a great strong
man I say he bends steel bars and blows
up hard water bottles and breaks wood
and steel and everything is crazy guy I
said his tremendous power said that he
is just sunshine here and the training
equipment and the food supplements I
said that he will blow everyone out of
water I'm a would just he will be
unbeatable and that's exactly what
happened Franco came here in 1969 and we
trained together and he won every
championship after that he won mr.
universe and mr. world and then
eventually even mr. Olympia after I
retired and we always worked that
together we always were very good
friends and very supportive and
everything and even the day and I'm very
proud of him because he spoke no English
unlike me who spoke a little English he
spoke absolutely none
and he went then and passed the entrance
examination to the Chiropractic College
and went
and with me to take some classes at the
Community College and got his English
better and his commander with the
language then passed the entrance
examination of the Chiropractic College
and then become became a chiropractor
and passed his board the first time not
like some of the guys that I worked out
with no gym did to try to two or three
times and then finally passed the third
time so I was really proud of him at
that and then he was just became an
expert in actual manipulation and
working with the body he had a special
talent for that
and it's why he has so many patients
today I remember uh watching his just
catastrophic leg explosion on on video
and then he's call me laying on a
stretcher and he says well just by
looking at my leg I can tell it's not
broken it's a dislocation he went on and
people thought he was was doctors
included as I understand it thought he
would never walk again and then he came
back and after you retired I guess in 80
or 81 he won that's when he won the
Olympia that's right yeah I mean it were
it was one of those unfortunate things
that the universal the back lock but
they did the strongmen acted there was a
hole in the road at that parking lot
and no one saw it it's you know was just
one of those unfortunate things and you
know Franco had to pay for it for the
mistake of it that the organizers made
and you know but he came back
I think Franco knew that I had a few
years before a heavy knee injury in 72
when I hurt my knee down in South Africa
doing squats and posing and and I came
back from that knee injury and my thighs
were bigger and better and more cut in
1973 at the Olympian that won the mr.
Olympia so he knew that you can come
back that if you have a great surgeon
and if you have great therapy after the
surgery that you can come back and be
better than ever and so that's exactly
what Franco did and you know he he went
through his surgery went through the
therapy and came back and then he was
squatting again with his 600 pounds like
it great ease
so incredible I want to talk about
language for a second when is the last
time you spoke German privately in a
conversation I sometimes speak with a
friend of mine Ralph Mela who is German
and so we sometimes speak German and
sometimes I would say it's a mishmash
between German and English because some
words are more accurate in German and
some words am were accurate in English
or it's easier to use in English it's a
you find more specific words in English
so we sometimes do you know like I said
mixture of both
and then Franco also speaks German and
so sometimes he will be talking in
English and then all of a sudden he will
get it get into a German thing and then
obviously we talk German and the same is
also with my nephew who is now a
prominent entertainment attorney here he
came I brought him over when he was 18
from Austria and from Portugal
he speaks Portuguese in his BIG's German
and French and also English now really
well since he has been the oldest years
and he also some them slips into the
German and then he's talking German and
sometimes in English it's a it's a it so
every so often I get to speak German
also well I enjoyed listening to an
audio total recall' your book and you
through and get witless give me this
kite yeah and then kept on moving and I
was like oh I like that because I lived
in Berlin for a short period of time
right and I really enjoyed it and also
also in a escape plan
I used the German and you know we did
this whole scene in Germany going crazy
I go crazy German so that was fun to do
and all that stuff but you know the
Austrians
have a different dialect it's kind of
the oceans are like southerners right
you know where people say huh what do
you say you know kind of things so that
the people people did have the high
german that they live up one north right
it's big more and more perfect like when
you go to Berlin it's like totally like
the way you ride a hog the German your
whole courage exactly uh now I was
having a conversation not too long ago
with Arianna Huffington
and she was telling me about a
conversation she had with Henry
Kissinger because she was taking accent
reduction classes and and Kissinger said
said no no you want to keep your accent
let's work so I wanted to ask you you've
taken accent reduction classes before
was there a point at which you know you
realized wow this is actually a strength
I don't want to get rid of this what the
object the objective was not to get rid
of the accent when you take accent
removal classes and dialect classes and
English classes that whole combination
it's all designed that you speak so
everyone understands you sometimes
people have a tendency foreigners have a
tendency of pronouncing a word so wrong
or with such wrong emphasis that people
don't know what they're talking about
and then when you correct them and they
say the right way then you totally
understand it and you're perfectly fine
so the trick is really to learn how to
enunciate and how to really speak the
language well and how not to rush and
throw words together that makes it an
almost impossible to understand so Henry
Kissinger is right everyone will always
remember him - Kissinger because of his
accent and because of his brilliance and
I think everyone will always remember
Arianna Huffington for her accent and
for being this woman that set out the
goal of creating this magazine and and
being highly successful and being always
politically oriented and policy you know
becoming a policy wonk and all those
kind of things but there are many of
those but what separates her is the
accent yeah in other way she talks you
know and the she's Greek and so she is
of course a different accent than I have
which made it really funny during the
debates maybe had the governor doriel
debates in Sacramento she was there in a
whining with a Greek accent and that was
did talking with German accent to notice
it was hilarious it just showed you know
how far in though kind of the world has
come California has come did obviously
they have two of the top candidates in
there all foreigners
at foreign accents I'm noted for running
for governor said to the I've been very
fascinated to look at your your film
career and hear the story of of twins
says I was hoping maybe you could tell
us the story of twins how twins came
together and how you guys structured
that deal because I didn't know anything
about that word twins came together
because I felt very strongly that I had
a side of me that is a very humorous
side and that if someone would be
patient enough and willing to work with
me as a director that they will be able
to bring that humor out of me and that's
you know something that is very
difficult because you can be humorous in
your private life but cannot pull it off
in a movie
there's many actors that have tried that
and were not successful so I felt you
know that I should really talk to Ivan
Reitman because I really loved
Ghostbusters and I said to myself god
that was so well directed and notice and
I just happened to run into him when
there was in Aspen and we were hanging
out there was Robin Williams and some
other people and we were all up there at
Snowmass and we were skiing and then at
night then before didn't be already
great time sitting by the fireplace and
choking around and Ivan Reitman would
say to me I know that I listen to you
and I see a side of you that has never
really been on screen and I said to him
I said you know I I would love to do a
comedy and I would love to bring that
side out if it is the innocence of me or
the naivety of me or the humour of me
whatever it is I said I would like to
see that on the screen a saying I think
it could be good and then he said okay
um as I said a message I want you to
work with me and to direct me in a movie
let's figure out what it should be and
he said okay I would love to do that I'm
gonna go home after Christmas after this
vacation and I'm going to look into and
develop a bunch of ideas and then
and you and I get together and then
picked the one that we like the best
he developed immediately within a short
period of time a bunch of ideas I think
there was five ideas and the one that we
both liked the most was called at the
experiment which then became twins
experiment we didn't like because I've
made German Austrian background so we
thought that it would be better to call
it twins and and we developed that
project got it written I came up with
the idea then of Danny DeVito that it
shouldn't be just someone that is acting
totally opposite of the way I am but it
should also look physically totally
opposite of the way I am and Ivan loved
that idea and then they went after Danny
DeVito and I remember we said then the
restaurant and we made a deal on a
napkin and wrote down you know this is
what we do we're gonna make the movie
for free we don't want to get any
salaries and we get a big back end and
these days I haven't should take this
deal didn't the end with the agent of
the studio and you do get the Tom
Pollock who was then running a Universal
Studio and Tom Pollock said this is
great we can make this movie for in the
16 and a half million dollars if there
you guys don't take a salary and you get
a big back end we're going to give you
37 percent of whatever it was together
that giving Danny Ivan and me and and we
worked out the percentage of what our
salaries are so whatever Danny got at
that time for movie versus what I got
for movie and versus with Ivan got for
directing so we worked it out
percentage-wise and that's how we ended
up dividing up the path amongst
ourselves and let me tell you I made
more money in that movie than any other
movie and that the gift keeps on giving
it's just wonderful and in and I
remember Tom Pollock after the movie
came out he said to me is is or I can
tell you as he says this is what you
guys did to me and he bent over he
turned around bent over he put his
pockets out and he says you [ __ ] me
clean me up
it's it was very funny he says I will
never make the deal again
but anyway so the movie was a huge hint
it came out just before Christmas and
throughout Christmas in New Year made
every day three to four million dollars
and which the day's Charmy will be of
course in a double or triple but it was
just huge and just went up to 129
million dollars domestically and I think
worldwide it was like three hundred and
two hundred and sixty million dollars or
something like that so it was really
very very successful and it like I said
it it ended up costing a thing around 18
million dollars the movie amazing so
amazing now you know I was when when I
hear story like that I think of the deal
that George Lucas did for Star Wars
where the studio is like a toys whatever
sure yeah you can have the toys then
they probably felt very much the same
way they're like wow we're not gonna
make that mistake again that's right ah
now you have a new film you have several
but Maggie and I'd love to for you to
tell people about it but I was also
curious maybe you could comment on this
but in this day and age why why you
don't say finance an entire film
yourself or crowdsource all the
financing is yourself so you're the only
not necessarily the only producer but
you're the sole owner of that film yeah
for some reason the other always felt
that I should keep the two apart and I
should not invest and put money in the
films this is a whole other business to
be in to finance movies and I think that
you know my strength is to be a
performer I think there's people out
there that are very good in financing
movies and raising money for movies or
people did run Studios notice and let
them do their job what they're doing I
do my job what I'm doing and this is why
I just never did that it's something
else if someone has a great idea to do a
documentary similar business as if this
goes to million dollars you know can you
help us with you're passionate about it
like for instance you know Brooklyn
Castle you know if someone would have
come to me and said hey here's a you
know documentary we want to do about
after-school programs in inner-city kids
I said wait a minute
two things I'm very passionate about a
love playing chess which is what it's
all about right the documentary how kids
in inner cities play chess and how they
become smart and how they stay off the
streets therefore not getting the
trouble with teenage pregnancy into
juvenile crime and order things and they
have adult supervision and they you know
they get confidence and there's a kids
did a 70% of them below the poverty line
so that's a great story and it is
something that both of them chess and in
the city kids after school programs they
feel passionate about so I would have
put money into that and that wouldn't
have been in it that would have just you
know done it because I think is a story
that ought to be told and so things like
that is something else but in my own
movies I don't know I never feel
comfortable with that idea keep them
separate yeah you know now I think about
it I do a lot of investing in startups
and sometimes people ask me why don't
you start your own startup and I
basically give them a very similar
answer it's like I'm already heavily
concentrated I'd like to keep the two
very separate so I'm glad you brought up
Brooklyn castle so a friend of mine was
was interviewed on this podcast named
Josh Waitzkin he was the basis for
searching for bobby fisher' so very well
known as a chess player and I've heard
you talk about the I think it's a 3:00
to 6:00 p.m. as the danger zone and I'm
on the advisory board for
donorschoose.org and a number of
nonprofits related to education why are
you so passionate about after-school
programs uh because I felt that then I
grew up even though we were very poor
but I had someone there 24 hours a day
for me to improve to learn to do sports
and to get attention and to get the love
and to get the discipline it was tough
upbringing but it was a combination of
you know great discipline and also the
love and but I felt like that that
having someone there with you 24 hours a
day from the time in the morning you get
up to the time you go to school and with
the teachers there and then with the
coaches there and that there was the
school principal and all of them and
then you go home and does your mother
they're helping you with your homework
and then in the evening your dad
helmand he goes takes it to the soccer
field and the sports with you and then
wind the ice curling and all those
things so I just felt when I watch and
go from school to school which I did
when there was the chairman of the
President's Council on physical fitness
and sports I traveled through all 50
states and visited one school after the
next and they're always at three o'clock
I felt like these kids are going out
there and then I saw half of them
standing around in front of the school
and then wandering around the other half
for getting picked up in the cinemas of
what happens with those kids out then
the the teachers or the principal who
always says is well you know the problem
today is is that so many parents are
working both of the parents are working
and they don't have really the ability
to pick up the kids from school and what
happens is a lot of these kids then get
into trouble you know and so then I
started looking into it
the idea of afterschool programs and
dies and I saw that there are
after-school programs around but they're
not really well organized and so I
stepped in I started after-school
programs here in Los Angeles we very
quickly then spread them all over
California and then all over the United
States and now we're in like thirteen or
fourteen cities all over the United
States including we're in Hawaii and and
they have been really beneficial and we
even passed an initiative in California
in 2002 which was the after-school
education and safety act that provides
an additional five hundred million
dollars for after-school programs in
California and because of that which
started going into effect in 2006
from that point on now every high school
and middle school in California has
after-school programs and then also
churches and other organizations that
are not connected to the school can also
get money for after-school programs so
they can have the after-school programs
so it really has become one of my
passions and it's it's just simply like
I said I had that upbringing I had the
attention 24 hours a day and it helped
me to be Who I am and I felt bad for the
kids when they don't get an equal shot
because the only way you can be
successful is if you really get this
kind of a
tension and if you don't get kind of in
the situation where you float around on
the streets then you get involved with
gangs and be drugs and with with
violence and you know like I said
teenage pregnancy and you become a
juvenile crimes and you end up in jail
it doesn't serve anybody and it costs
the community a lot of money and the way
I got Republican support for that in
California and had them in towards my
initiative was because I show to them
that for every dollar we spend we save
three dollars down the line and so from
a fiscal point of view they endorsed it
even though they don't like the you know
the nanny state thing and do have
government step in and do the job for
parents the Democrats endorsed it for
that they thought the government is
responsible and we ought to do something
because is the new challenge that 70% of
the kids come from homes where both of
the parents are working and they do not
have time for the kids in the afternoon
so who is helping this kid with home
work who is helping this kid with
tutoring and with sports programs and
adult supervision and giving the kid
that love that the kid needs and the
confidence-building that the kidneys and
for that after-school program is the
number one answer to the problem we have
seen it over and over what great success
rate we have had with after-school
programs and hopefully the movement will
grow and eventually every child would
have the opportunity to join an
after-school program if they don't have
a parent at home that can help them with
all those things and everybody listening
I'll obviously provide links to all the
organizations that Arnold's involved
with and I encourage you and implore you
to consider becoming involved supporting
or becoming a mentor a big brother or
sister of some type I grew up on Long
Island and I had I was competitive
athlete I was a wrestler for a very long
time that kept me out of trouble and I
can see how easily both my parents
worked many of my friends growing up
there ended up overdosing on drugs
becoming involved with drugs because
they had idle hands during that period
of time but they did the other thing you
have to understand is when you are a
foreigner an immigrant did you come over
here and you enjoy
the unbelievable opportunities that
America is to offer it is natural that
you feel like you want to give something
back and I felt like when that was the
German of the President's Council in
them when it was a trainer for the
Special Olympics and then with the
after-school programs it was my way also
of giving back because people listened
to me because at that point I was a
celebrity already and I had the
tremendous power of influence because if
my movies nor it says a missive I might
as well use this power of influence for
something good and also give something
back to the country that's why I was
arraigned for governor and order stuff
so I think it just feels good to do
something for people they need help
that's you know what life is all about
totally agreed and the end for those of
you out there who've read my stuff I get
asked by readers a lot you know what's
what's the key to happiness and I think
if you're not sure how to make yourself
happy make someone else happy help
someone else and the payback is enormous
up Arnold when you hear the word
successful who's the first person who
comes to mind I think that people like
Buffett Bill Gates Larry Ellison Elon
Musk I mean people like that right
because it's the first thing that you do
think of when you hear about success
that a really worldwide known for their
success but then there's another there's
other layers
you know like for instance you know he
cannot avoid someone like Nelson Mandela
who showed to the world about
forgiveness and to the world about
tolerance and inclusion and the job that
he did in South Africa was not only a
great job for South Africa but it was a
great job for the whole world because
inspired everybody to be remotely like
that in the no one can really be like
that a bit because it was really very
very special and I was very fortunate to
meet him twice and to work with him in
Special Olympics in South Africa and to
be at his prison cell Robben Island and
have him showed me around Norris and I
had time to talk with him and spent a
day with him twice so he's definitely
one of those guys Mikhail Gorbachev
I mean someone that grows up on the
communism and then when he's on the top
realizes that the system doesn't work
and then dismantle it I mean think about
the the the hoods but that takes right
dude to do that did well didn't he tell
em any both testicles it's right there
unbelievable leadership you know and
envision and all that or even sports I
mean if you think about Muhammad Ali how
can you not think about success and not
think about him because that guy was so
successful but also not only successful
in sports but also in generosity I mean
that he gave everything away
I'm he will goes through the upward
lives I see see someone that there's no
money will give him $100 pill in it so
he was an extraordinary athlete so
there's a lot of people like that I
think that when he goes through history
also this someone that I just thought of
that I should mention that is
Cincinnatus and he was a Roman Emperor
and in the Roman and
hyah and he why I admire him and as
America Cincinnati the city is named
after him because he was a big Idol of
George Washington Oz and the reason why
he is a great example of success is
because he was asked reluctantly due to
step in into power become the Emperor
and to help because the Rome was about
to get annihilated by oldest wars and
battles and so the step in there and to
help them and he was a farmer
powerful guy and he went took on the
challenge took over Rome took over the
deed the army and won the war and then
after they won the war he is felt that
he has done his mission why was asked to
go and be the Emperor and he gave the
ring back and went back to farming and
he didn't only do this once he did it
twice they went back later on to him
once again
and when the men did try to overthrow
the Empire within and they asked him
back and he came back he cleaned them up
the mess it was through great great
leadership which he had the tremendous
good leadership quality and bringing
people together and then again he gave
the drink back and went back to farming
that's and to be as it we all know it's
very addictive yeah to be powerful it's
very addictive and I know how difficult
it was for me to let go of being
governor and then all of a sudden you're
not sitting there and making decisions
about what's going to happen you know
that the financial crisis what's going
to happen to the regulations to
greenhouse regulations what's going to
happen you know to our you know
high-speed rail what's happening with
the university and you're not the
anymore you know making the decisions
it's very hard to let that goes imagine
someone like that to let go to be the
Emperor it's a whole different thing and
so so to me that's very admirable in
them and I think about success
he's also somebody every with net
category I'll have to do some more
research on
do we have time for just a few more
Coons uh so feel free to not answer this
if you don't want to but this is almost
the opposite last question when you
think of the word punchable who's the
first what's the first face that comes
to mind punchable I never thought about
that
most people don't walk around thinking
about it now so I don't think there's
anyone that I can think of right now
okay I was worried thinking about asking
this that you might just reach across
and knock my front teeth into the back
of my head but the is there a particular
do you have a favorite book or book that
you've given to people as a gift the
most what would this one book that I
have actually since it was just
Christmas they'd have given away a lot
of copies and this is a book about
Winston Churchill by Mayor Boris Johnson
I don't know if you're familiar with him
is the mayor of London and he's a real
interesting character they think that he
could be eventually Prime Minister of
England very talented guy another party
servant but the people's servant and he
came up with the Boris bike that has not
bicycles all over London that you can
did anyone can just take and ride around
with the bikes and then now they have
this in all over Europe in France in
Paris in Vienna and everywhere they all
took this idea that people would drive
less in the city if they have the
possibility to get a bike from a bike
stand and so he's a very interesting guy
so he I did not even know that he is you
know this extraordinary writer at the
same time but I was in in London for a
promotion and the SONA bookshelf and my
suite this book Winston Churchill of
course I admired Winston George is one
of those guys that they really love and
so I took this book down from the
bookshelf and then I look nurse said Oh
Boris Johnson the mayor he wrote they
said I got to get that so I put it back
and then Daniel wrote down is sick oh oh
yeah oh yeah so so anyway so we wrote
down the title and we wrote down you
know order information and then we
we got it as a Christmas gift for a lot
of people but the other book that I have
given I mean hundreds of copies though
is free to choose by Milton Friedman and
it kind of lays out why the private
sector is really the answer to a lot of
the problems that we have in that
government and I think it's a real great
kind of a a philosophic kind of a book
about how to approach our problems if
it's education if this economic growth
and all those kind of various different
issues you know he lays it out it's a
very simple book to read but it is very
good and it doesn't it makes an impact
than you when you read it and the other
one I think is California the Kevin
Starr Oh Kevin saw was our librarian a
state librarian and he has written more
books in California than anyone so if
anyone is at all interested in the book
about California you know what makes
California unique and special and the
history of it the political history of
in all the little details I mean that's
a good book to have so it's a it's a
it's a great gift especially when I was
governor and you give people gift if you
give it of course of California a book
about California and so on so let's say
you know the kind of reading that I like
that I like to share with other people
wonderful I've just one more question
than I'd love to hear where we can learn
more about all the projects that you're
up to and that is I've heard you
mentioned Transcendental Meditation in
passing briefly do you meditate
I don't made a date now but I got
heavily into it in the 70s and I
remember there was a time in my life
where I felt like everything is just
kind of coming together and I did not
find a way or couldn't find a way of
keeping the things separate so it was
always when I was thinking about I was
thinking about at the same time my
bodybuilding career I was thinking about
my movie career I was thinking about the
documentary pumping heart that we're
shooting right now and the movie stay
hungry they were just finished shooting
and the my investment in the apartment
building it is this kind of to get the
financing from the bank and all this
kind of stuff was always coming together
and at the same time I was training for
the mr. Olympia come
in South Africa and there was training
right here Gold's Gym I remember there
was all the camera equipment around five
hours a day in my face and then someone
in the middle of squatting was trying to
change the battery pack I'm a I'm a
lifting belt and all astir say I was
like you know eventually I felt like I
got to do something about it because I
have such great opportunities here and
everything is happening and everything
is going my way but I'm just
clustering everything into one big
problem rather than separating it out
and having calm and peace and and being
happy and so I put total in a coincident
I ran into this guy that I've run into
many times in the beach very very
pleasant man who told me that he is a
teacher in Transcendental Meditation and
I said well it's interesting you mention
it is it because I feel like I should do
something because I feel like you know
I'm just overly worried and anxieties
and all this stuff and I feel like
certain pressures that they've never
felt before and he says oh since Arnold
it's not uncommon
it's very common a lot of people go
through this this is why people use
meditation Transcendental Meditation is
one way of dealing with the problem and
he was very good in selling it because
he didn't say it's the only answer
he just is one of many and he says why
don't you try it
he says I'm a teacher there I've been
Westwood I would not be able to teach
you since we have a friendly of we're
friends and we I have made uses there
will be another teacher that it will
give you a mantra and Probab and teacher
how to do it and then I can help you
after that is because I will be teaching
abuse so why don't we come up on
Thursday and I will be there I wouldn't
reduce it to the folks up there that
went up there took a class and I went
home after that net then tried it I said
mister I gotta give it a shot and that
did 20 minutes in morning 20 minutes at
night and I would say within 14 days
three weeks I got to the point where I
really could disconnect my mind and as
they say defined as few seconds of this
connection and rejuvenate
that the mind and and also learn how to
focus more and to calm down and I did
that for it and that's all the effect
right away that I was much more calm
about all the challenges that were
facing me and I continued doing that
then for a year and by that time I felt
like I think that I've mastered this I
think that now I don't feel overwhelmed
anymore and they really felt kind of it
was one of the things we are in the
Transcendental Meditation was kind of
anxiety and pressure meeting around the
corner
tranquility you know this is kind of
forty but it felt and and so I was happy
from the opponent and even the day I
still benefit from that because I don't
merge and bring things together and see
everything is one big problem I take on
one challenge at the time and when I go
and I study my script for a movie then
that time that day when I study my
script for a movie I don't let anything
else interfere in that not just
concentrate on that so and the other
thing that everyone is that there's many
forms of meditation in a way because
like when I study and I've worked really
hard it takes the ultimate amount of
concentration I can only do it for 45
minutes maybe maybe an hour but then I
have to kind of run off and maybe play
chess in a play chess for 15 minutes
then I can go back and have all the
energy in the world again and jump right
back and then continue on with my
workers as if I've not done it at all
the day right it's like I'm fresh and
that's another way I think of meditation
and then I also figured out that I could
use my workouts as a form of meditation
because I concentrate so much on the
muscle and I have my mind inside the
bicep when I do my curls I have my mind
inside the pectoral muscles when I do my
bench press so I'm really inside and
it's like
gained a form of meditation because you
have no chance of thinking or
concentrating on anything else at that
time but just that training that you do
and so there's many ways of meditation
and I benefit from all of those and I'm
today much kama because of that in much
more organized and much more tranquil
because of that this whole conversation
makes me want to go tackle the world I
love it and I really appreciate all of
your time where can people and of course
I'll link to all these things and the
show notes for folks but where can
people learn more about what you're up
to what would you like to share with
people well I think that you know people
they know my ambitions in the movie
business you know that I love doing
movies but I think because of my
interest in public policy after my
governorship I have been started at USC
the USC what's in the Institute that
deals with some of the issues that I
felt very passionate about during the
time of us governor on the event
beforehand which was in a political
reform we were very successful in doing
redistricting reform in California and
open primaries and so on which now
brings politicians much more to the
center but this is not the only thing
there's many more things that need to be
accomplished in California and
nationwide so our Institute deals with
that it does it deals you know with
stem-cell research it deals with the
economic growth opportunities it deals
with education after-school programs
programs and so on and especially also
with environmental issues and you know I
have an environmental organization on
top of that which is the r20 which deals
with sub-national governments because I
feel always very strongly that while we
are striving towards a Kyoto to treaty
and be older than the nations in the
world come together and I hope that
they're going to be successful this year
in Paris in December I at the same time
want sub-national governments like
California and other states and other
provinces and cities to set their own
goals and not the wait just for this
treaty
but to have the from the top-down
approach which the international treaty
will be and from the bottom-up
grassroots level approach from the
bottom up because when those two meet
then we really create critical mass
that's what it's all about so I want to
continue pushing towards every new
Herbal energy future it is my crusade
it's as much a crusade as my fitness
crusade was for the last 45 years and
we've been pretty successful with that
so I hope that we're going to be
successful with that too but it does
need everyone to buy in and everyone to
participate and that's why I go around
the world and give speeches on
environmental issues and try to bring
countries together make sure that this
year it will be a huge success but at
the same time have sub-national
governments set their own goals and do
exactly what we did in California in
California we didn't wait for Washington
we didn't wait for a UN treaty or
anything like this we set the goal of
reducing our greenhouse gases per 20
percent the 25 percent by the year 2020
and 85 percent by the year 2050 we
created the million extra solar roofs in
California we lower the fuel standards
here we set the goal due to upped the
renewables from 25 percent to 48 percent
by the year 2020 so these are all things
that we did we didn't wait for
Washington and so we want other states
to do the same thing and luckily
California showed great leadership and
now we see other sub-national
governments doing the same thing and
that's regions $20 is our 20 regions
twinning and people can find you on
twitter at schwarzenegger that's right
wonderful all right is there anything
else that ah that you'd like to mention
before we close out yeah Amaze we doing
another fundraiser with our maze and the
last time we did for the after-school
programs which we talked about earlier
do fundraising all the time because they
always need money and for every dollar
we can sit you know send more kids to
after-school programs so we always
raising money so the last time we had a
tank drive and destroy things
amazing amazing idea if there's a model
tank right there behind you oh yeah this
is so that the big tank the real tank
m47 for my military days it's the real
tank so we basically you know
was Weber won the bid came out and you
could sit with me in a in the tank and
then we crushed things together pianos
toilet balls living rooms and everything
okay did he pick I just destroyed and be
raised over a million dollars from that
which was really great
did a lot of fun at the same time this
time instead of you know destroying
things with the tank we blow things up
so this will be the new fundraiser which
we were going to start I think in very
soon as in February as a matter fact so
there's another thing that I'm doing is
always raising money for the
after-school programs and is that is the
link going to be the same as the last
okay amazed calm / Arnold I'll put that
in the show notes as well sir thank you
so much for the timer but it has been
wonderful
thank you until next time thank you for
listening folks thank you for listening
to this episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I'll be putting links to all the books
mentioned resources websites etc at
4-hour workweek dot-com forward slash
Arnold and if you enjoyed this episode
two things number one I'm hoping to get
some bonus questions answered from
Arnold and I'll be putting those on
Facebook facebook.com forward slash Tim
Ferriss GIM fer are is two hours and two
S's and if you enjoyed this episode
there are several others of mine that I
think you will love the first is with
tony robbins of course advisor to people
like Andre Agassi top hedge fund
managers Bill Clinton Serena Williams
the list goes on and on about his
morning rituals and routines among many
other things just go to 4-hour workweek
comm forward slash Tony to check that
out and then my vote for the most
interesting man in the world in real
life is Kevin Kelly and if you don't
know who he is or if you have heard the
name before either way this is an
incredible three-part episode you got to
check it out it is 4-hour workweek
dot-com forward slash Kevin and until
next time thank you very much for
listening
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by on it I have used on it products for
years if you look in my kitchen in my
garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it calm
forward-slash Tim that's onn i t.com
forward slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force
I like Alpha brand check it all out on
it comm forward slash Tim the Tim
Ferriss show is also brought to you by
99 designs 99 designs is your one-stop
shop for anything graphic design related
you need a logo you need a website you
need a business card or anything else
you get an original design from
designers around the world who submit
drafts for you to review you are happy
or you get your money back and I have
used 99 designs for book cover ideas for
the 4-hour body which went to number one
New York Times for banner ads and you
can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim you can also get a
free $99 upgrade if you want to give it
a shot that's 99designs comm forward
slash Tim